I slid into his dance I followed him and
he followed me and I just swamed over
right on in Kelsey ballerini gets candid
about her love life revealing she made
the first move on Chase Stokes following
her divorce from Morgan Evans I'm an
open book
the country singer opens up on the call
her daddy podcast about her relationship
with the outer Bank star am I single
um am I single
um nope and Kelsey admits their
relationship kicked off when she slid
into his DMS I've never seen the show
and but I just knew of him
um and yeah so I followed him and he
followed me and I just swand over right
on in the two first sparked romance
rumors in January when Chase shared this
cuddled up pick on Instagram and tagged
Kelsey a lot of good things going on we
had been hanging out and people got a
photo of us
um at the game at the championship and
so that was kind of just going and he
was like I mean it's gonna keep going so
should I just like poke the bear and I
was like sure and the poking the bear
was like a photo of me just like leaning
anything on him E.T was with Chase last
week just hours after Saturday Night
Live announced their upcoming slate of
hosts and musical guests including
Kelsey who will perform on March 4th I
mean she's the best and I'm so excited
for her and everything happening in her
career right now Kelsey says the two
started talking in early December just a
few months after she confirmed in August
2022 she filed for divorce from her
husband Morgan Evans whom she married in
2017. I think what we've both learned
about each other is we both need space
like we're both so Independent by Nature
we'll have days where we're like okay I
have the upstairs for an hour and we
just kind of declare our our space the
two settled their Divorce by October
2022 but not without things getting ugly
who you marry is not who you divorce he
even released a song about their split
how long have you been waiting to take
our pictures down how long have you been
breaking why am I just finding it you
know as he's putting out a song
about being blindsided he's taking half
the house that he didn't pay for but now
Kelsey says she's moved on and is having
fun I think I grieved a lot of marriage
in the marriage and so I think I was
ready to open back up why not yeah why
not I've never really dated I don't know
how it works I'm like well let's just
put ourselves out there Let's Just Vibe
and um and it's it's been fun
[Music]
thank you